hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
heute zu einem neuen video ich habe in
letzter zeit häufiger videos hochladen
in denen ich böse kommentare hater
kommentare witzige bescheuerte total
bekloppte kommentare einfach vorgelesen
habe und darauf reagiert habe oder habe
ich den kalender geguckt habe gesehen
heute ist montag ok montag ist er sonst
haben wir motor gesellschaft relativ
uncool allerdings habe ich dann einfach
mal das letzte video der allgemeinen
sehr viele leute ich soll das doch
einfach mal mit netten kommentaren
machen weil mir sehr viele leute etwas
sagen wollten was jetzt nicht unbedingt
böse oder bekloppt ist falls das
irgendwie gerade sinn ergeben hat genau
diesen habe ich dann heute mittag am
besten im chat gesagt deswegen könnt ihr
jetzt auf instagram laser lokal thema
mein neuestes bild in dem kommentar
schreiben was ihr mit meinem videos
verbindet also das quasi alle leute die
irgendwas mit meinen videos verbinden
oder mir schon immer etwas nettes sagen
wollten das jetzt unter das bild
schreiben sollen und ich dann daraus
sachen raus nehmen oder irgendwie
tarnung 25 kommentare oder so jetzt im
video vorlesen werde deswegen heute mal
so ein bisschen was anderes als jetzt
nicht so wirklich komme die yamaha mehr
so mal eure community in den vordergrund
stellen und nicht so meinen content
gerade also ich lese daran mal die
kommentare vor anke dass deine eltern
kein kondom benutzt haben als sie nicht
zeigte seine videos haben mich immer auf
wenn es mir so richtig beschissen geht
und dafür bin ich dir einfach
unglaublich darüber dank dir mag ich
tomatensaft durch deine videos hat mein
bruder angefangen sich konditionell und
ganz simulator zu zocken
du bist der hammerschlag ein video von
ihr habe ich hab mir letzten mittwoch
bei einer vorstellung 1 lukas meili
shirt unter dem hemd an und heute
beginne ich dort zu arbeiten hatte mir
also glück war ich finde es bei den
videos gut dass du auch mal irgendwas
werbung macht ohne dass es gleich der
produktplatzierung ist durch seine
videos habe ich mein lachen wieder
gefunden da ich ein sehr komischen humor
habe die nicht wieder teilen du hast den
sehr gut getroffen mein sohn und ich
feiere nicht einfach nie auf damit sowas
der ersten let's play den ich geschaut
habe und durch seine videos habe ich
einige andere youtuber kennengelernt
deswegen sich mein leben enorm
es hat deswegen ein großes danke an ich
luca deine videos sind so toll immer
wenn ich die sehe kann ich besser packen
und mehr lassen ich mag deine letzte
place und real live videos ich feiert
eine witzige stimme manchmal machst
wegen dir marie stimme jetzt auch immer
unbewusst im unterricht dein videos
verbinde ich dass ich immer lachen
musste ich deine videos habe ich zum
beispiel angefangen sport zu machen
deine videos beziehungsweise deine
person im allgemeinen hat mich dazu
aufgebaut hat neue dinge auszuprobieren
ich habe angefangen den mut zu fassen
und zu machen was ich will ich verbinde
mit deinen videos also sehr viel
dankbarkeit lachen spaß und vor allem
mut verbindet mit deinen videos meine
beste freundin weil ich sie durch deine
videos kennen gelernt habe ich habe
durch seine videos meine beste freundin
die ich seit über sechs jahren kenne
kennengelernt ich bin in eine neue
schule gekommen und dort konnte ich
keinen doch dann bemerkte ich dass die
anderen alle fans von mir waren wir
wurden dicke freunde und sprachen fast
immer über dich und die coolen videos
danke dafür ohne dich wäre ich nicht so
selbstbewusst ich habe eine wundervolle
beste freundin namens kia und wir beide
schauen deine videos und reden immer
darüber und eben verbindet uns das auch
wenn es sich irgendwie blöd anhört als
mein bester freund vor zwei jahren in
die usa zurück es war sein vater wieder
zur armee musste war es ein ziemlicher
schock und von monat zu monat wurde der
kontakt immer weniger bis wir irgendwann
gar keinen kontakt mehr hatten vor fünf
monaten hatten wir dann den link zu
deinem jelly beans video mit granie
geschenke haben gemeint das können wir
auch machen ich meine da nur hh sehr
witzig seine antwort auf band ein jetzt
macht die tür auf ich dachte zuerst er
macht einen witz allerdings hat er dann
wirklich vor der türe stand und meint er
wohnt jetzt wieder genau hier genau eine
straße über mir und dass er ein video
von dir genommen hat weil ich seine
videos so feiere ich fand das so nice
dass er sich das hat einfallen lassen
danke für deinen leisten videos ich bin
tatsächlich erst durch seine instagram
account zu den videos gekommen da du
einfach so sympathisch und natürlich
rüberkommt auch wenn du dir das nicht
angucken wie jetzt wollte ich dir nur
sagen dass du mich mit deinem video echt
motiviert ich weiß nicht wie du es
machst oder was aber du bist echt gut
darin eine videos haben eine besondere
gute qualität außerdem liebe ich es wenn
du sprichst wie beispielsweise den
girlfriend ex von dirk max übrigens
viele menschen technisch zum lachen und
zauberten ein lächeln ins gesicht du
bist du nun dein videos und verstellt
sich nicht und ich war das dass du auf
dem bielefeld wird aber jedes verdammte
mal verpasse ich dich irgendwie mit dir
verbinde ich familie
warum ich habe mein vater seit zwei
monaten nach
einer geburt nicht gesehen ich traf ich
auf der straße und wir haben ein foto
gemacht und dann noch einmal stand ein
paar meter weiter an da warst du schon
längst weg mein vater er hat mich wie
auch immer sofort erkannt jetzt mein
vater wieder bei meiner mutter und mir
und nein das ist kein fake auch wenn er
sich so total übertrieben anhört ist es
wirklich so passiert mit ihm verbinde
ich meine neu entdeckte liebe zu youtube
vor ein paar jahren habe ich
verschiedene youtuber geschaut als
angabe ist so ein umbruch und youtuber
wie beauty pettis und die lobbys
entstanden ich fand den humor so schlimm
und habe seitdem einen riesigen bogen um
youtube gemacht vor ein paar monaten
habe ich durch zufall ein video von ihr
gefunden und schauer seitdem wieder
regelmäßig youtube vor allem neben
deinem video du hast einen knall einen
positiv
du bist einfach du machst dein ding und
das ist gut so das macht dich und deine
konzert extrem sympathisch deine videos
versüßen einem den tag und vertreiben
die schlechte laune ich habe durch nicht
conny ditz kennengelernt erst dank dir
einer meiner besten freunde und wir
werden uns dieses jahr auf der gamescom
treffen danke an die ich dass ich ihn
kennenlernen durfte letztes jahr mit
seinen kanal kurz vor dem video des
entdeckte wurde direkt fan natürlich
wollte ich dich dann an dem video days
treffen ich war nur an dem schott aber
von ihr fordert keine spur es war das
schon zu ende und ich habe schon beinahe
geheult und dann sind meine freundin und
ich nochmal rumgelaufen an standest du
da du hast ja ein kissen und ein shirt
gesteckt und gesagt komm wir machen ein
foto wie ich schwanger bin
so ist das wenn man mich mal trifft also
ehrlich gesagt habe ich dich erst zwei
drei tagen abonniert und hast mir glaube
ich den fettesten lauffläche überhaupt
gegeben ich meine deine ganzen videos
ich habe mit falschen halbzeit verlief
angefangen und ich habe tränen gelacht
dafür danke ich dir meine beste freundin
hat mich dann noch nicht gebracht und
ich danke dir so kraska habe ich dich
und ich kann gar nicht mehr richtig
lesen ich habe jetzt schon 25 kommentare
gelesen ich bin nur an bührer
natürlich deine videos haben mich in
mein bruder endlich mal eine
gemeinsamkeit durch dich habe ich
gelernt dass man nicht sein komplettes
privatleben offen legen muss um gemocht
zu werden und dass die menschen den über
dem herzen liegt werth ob deine meinung
lege deine entscheidungen akzeptieren
ist doch mal ein schöner abschluss das
war heute ein bisschen anderes video und
zwar ist es ja sonst immer so wenn ich
fan content in form von kommentaren oder
video dz zeigt und präsentiere das
darauf was ein bisschen überspitzt und
bescheuert reagiere das war heute
allerdings mal komplett anders weil ich
mir gedacht habe ich nämlich schöne
kommentare rein
sehr viele leute gesagt haben ja ich bin
echt mal gern was positive schreiben
aber kann sie das nicht auch meinen
videos zeigen und so ein bisschen nicht
zu diesen hate charakter im vordergrund
stellt sondern mal so ein bisschen so
liebe zeigen und nicht immer nur so
bescheuert sein
ich hoffe euch das video gefallen ich
fand's einfach ultras zu sehen dass so
viele leute mir unter die bilder
geschrieben haben so junge luca ich hab
dich dich meine freundin kennengelernt
ich habe da meinen vater wieder gewohnt
so voll kranke sache natürlich kommen
jetzt behaupten dass vielleicht ein paar
sachen nach vorne stimmung und erlogen
sind oder so habe ich merkte dabei
fantreffen wenn er beispielsweise eine
mutter mit ihrer tochter ankommt und die
tochter dann wenn sie mich sieht und
dann die mutter sagt ja das ist das
einzige was meine tochter jeden tag
schaut da setzen uns abends hin und
gucken dass das sowas ist halt nicht
erfunden
deswegen und dass das finde ich halt
immer ganz schön dass oder total crazy
das irgendwie durch ganz normale videos
durch das was ich mache leute froh
werden und irgendwie miteinander
verbunden
ich weiß nicht was ich sagen will aber
ich glaube ihr versteht was sich
irgendwie zu sagen meine tun ich was
rede ich dann schon wieder wenn euch
sowas gefallen hat freue ich mich über
eine bewertung und morgen geht es weiter
mit gaming oder comedy oder irgendein